entsetzen in israel mindestens 45
menschen sterben bei einer massenpanik
impfen da wo es dringend ist weil corona
besonders in sozialen brennpunkten
grassiert sollen dort jetzt mobile teams
helfen eine alte schuld viele skulpturen
den deutschen museen sind raubgut aus
der kolonialzeit nigeria soll einige
jetzt zurück bekommen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und wir kommen
zu den nachrichten an diesem freitag
norbert lehmann ist auch mit dabei für
den sport ein schöner von mir seit der
korona pandemie war dies das erste große
religiöse fest im fast durchgehend
israel zehntausende meist ultraorthodoxe
hatten sich aufgemacht um zu feiern
als plötzlich eine massenpanik ausbricht
in dem gedränge viel zu viele menschen
auf zu engem raum kommen mindestens 45
von ihnen ums leben darunter wohl auch
kinder
das unglück spielte sich im norden
israels ab amberg meron der
wallfahrtsort am jüdischen feiertag lag
aber um mehr
an diesem tag wird der aufstand gegen
die römer im zweiten jahrhundert nach
christus gefeiert
offenbar waren viel mehr als die
ursprünglich zugelassenen 10.000
menschen gekommen
michael bewerunge berichtet eigentlich
müssen die toten nach jüdischem brauch
vor beginn des sabbats heute beerdigt
werden doch viele opfer sind noch gar
nicht identifiziert ein ganzes land in
trauer und unter schock
auch im iran haben die ersthelfer das
geschehen noch nicht verarbeitet ich kam
und sah all die toten kinder
das handy von einem kind klingelte
sanitäter packten die leiche des kindes
in einen sack einer von ihnen weinten
was soll ich mit dem handy machen hat er
gefragt in den sack schmeißen es war
furchtbar
das singen und tanzen amberg miron war
diesmal besonders ausgelassen nach dem
harten corona ja und dem ende der
beschränkungen an die hunderttausend
orthodoxe waren solak warum er nach rom
gepilgert
die anlagen aber sind zum teil
provisorisch an einem steilen abgang
kommt es zur katastrophe
die menge kommt ins rutschen menschen
fallen stolpern übereinander panik
bricht aus
zu den vielen toten kommen mehr als 150
verletzte bisher
wir wurden nach links und rechts
geschoben sich bemerkte menschen unter
mir die nicht mehr atmete andere schrien
dass sie keine luft bekommen dann
verschwunden die rufe
retter kommen schlecht durch ein- und
ausgänge sind offenbar falsch
dimensioniert die menschen laufen in
eine tödliche falle
der boden war aus metall und sehr
glitschig jemand rutschte aus und dann
fielen die anderen über ihn
ministerpräsident netanjahu versprach am
unglücksort eine schnelle untersuchung
aber er und die polizei stehen in der
kritik
es seien zu viele menschen auf das
gelände gelassen notausgänge zu spät
geöffnet worden
für den sonntag ist in ganz israel
ein tag der nationalen trauer ausgerufen
zurück nach deutschland schauen wir an
dieser stelle auf die korona zahlen
dort hält der trend an sinken erneut so
meldet das robert koch institut heute 24
1329 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden 3214 weniger als vor einer woche
306 neue todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
153,4 der niedrigste wert seit zwei
wochen zu viel unterschiedlichkeit kann
vertrauen zerstören das sagt heute
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
er rückt damit die verschiedenen regeln
für vollständig geimpfte in deutschland
mittlerweile hat die justizministerin
einen entwurf für eine bundesweite
verordnung vorgelegt wichtigste punkte
menschen mit vollen impfschutz und cobit
genesene müssten sich nicht mehr an die
ausgangssperre halten
sie dürften wieder deutlich mehr
kontakte haben und bräuchten etwa beim
friseur keinen corona test mehr
andrea maurer das tempo beim impfen
macht nun auch dem gesetzgeber druck was
dürfen geimpft
während der innenminister kürzlich noch
vor schnellschüssen warnte gibt die
justizministerin gas
der schutz von leben oder gesundheit
anderer ist ein grund um in grundrechte
und grundrechte einzuschränken aber wenn
der wegfällt weil von geimpften von
genesenen keine oder nur eine sehr
geringe gefahr ausgeht dann muss ich
auch die einschränkungen zurücknehmen
noch vor lambrechts verordnungsentwurf
haben einige bundesländer fakten
geschaffen
in acht ländern von bayern bis sachsen
anhalt sind geimpfte und getestete
bereits vollkommen oder teilweise
gleichgestellt bundestagspräsident
wolfgang schäuble übt scharfe kritik
jetzt haben wir schon wieder den zustand
dass sich eine reihe von ländern nicht
an die absprachen hält ein zu großes maß
an unterschiedlichkeit kann vertrauen
zerstören
kritik auch vom städte und gemeindebund
sie müssen jemandem erklären dass er in
bayern als zweimal geimpft andere rechte
hat als in nordrhein westfalen oder
einem anderen bundesland so was muss
doch bundeseinheitlich erfolgen
der entwurf aus lambrechts haus sollen
nun übers wochenende in der regierung
abgestimmt werden anfang der woche dann
mit bundestag und bundesrat
der gesundheitsminister hält eine
entscheidung in der bundesratssitzung am
freitag für möglich der
regierungssprecher spricht von einem
ehrgeizigen zeitplan
deswegen wollen wir einen entwurf
einbringen der somit bundestag und
bundesrat geeint ist dass er
mehrheitsfähig ist und ein schneller
durch lauf durchs parlament möglich ist
druck machen unterdessen auch gerichte
mecklenburg vorpommerns einreiseverbot
für zweitwohnungsbesitzer wurde heute
vom oberverwaltungsgericht greifswald
für unrechtmäßig erklärt das verbot
behandlung vollständig geimpfte und
nicht geimpfte gleich die
landesregierung muss die regelung nun
überarbeiten der korona impfstoff von
biontech könnte bald auch bei
jugendlichen von 12 bis 15 jahren
eingesetzt werden
das unternehmen hat bei der europäischen
arzneimittelbehörde die zulassung
beantragt
inzwischen haben 22,4 millionen menschen
in deutschland zumindest ihre erste
impfung gegen korona erhalten
das sind 26,9 prozent intensivmediziner
fordern jetzt verstärkt in sozialen
den punkten zu impfen denn auf den
intensivstationen legen
überdurchschnittlich viele menschen aus
ärmeren schichten dominic miller sl
berichtet impfen im sozialen brennpunkt
hier soll es nächste woche losgehen am
kölnberg lieben 8000 menschen ein
geteiltes echo
wen geht ich mache die und meine familie
auch die einen vor die anderen glauben
nicht an das virus vielleicht liegt die
inzidenz hier auch deshalb bei weit über
500 kölns oberbürgermeisterin wird für
die vorrangige impfung als schutz für
alle kölnerinnen und kölner deswegen ist
es ganz wichtig dass wir das also alle
auch akzeptieren als maßnahmen der
gefahrenabwehr die uns allen nützt
darum geht es doch auch mediziner halten
es für dringend geboten nun verstärkt in
sozialen brennpunkten zu impfen
auf den intensivstationen legen
überdurchschnittlich viele menschen aus
ärmeren bevölkerungsschichten neue
analyse habe gezeigt dass die
intelligenz von corona in stadtteilen
mit ängsten wohnverhältnissen besonders
hoch ist und hier haben wir eine große
chance mit mobilen impf teams auf die
menschen zuzugehen in besonders
betroffenen gebieten kann von der
priorisierung abgewichen werden
bestätigt heute der
bundesgesundheitsminister
dies sei unbedingt sinnvoll ich kann mir
auch gut vorstellen dass man vielleicht
in der perspektive auch in der innen-
oder an der kirche oder der moschee
impft je nachdem wo menschen leicht zu
erreichen sind dann auch ins angebote zu
machen
am montag könnte es am kölnberg los
gehen vorausgesetzt dass das land bis
dahin zusätzliche impfdosen bereit
stellt denn kleist auch weggenommen
werden soll niemandem etwas
die dritte corona welle hat die deutsche
wirtschaft in den ersten drei monaten
des jahres schrumpfen lassen um 1,7
prozent das ist eine erste schätzung des
statistischen bundesamtes eingebrochen
ist vor allem der private konsum besser
lief es bei den exporten
die haben die wirtschaft gestützt für
das zweite quartal rechnen volkswirte
wieder mit wachstum
um der wirtschaft zu helfen in der
pandemie hat die bundesregierung bereits
milliarden an steuergeldern ausgegeben
und weitere maßnahmen beschlossen
ein wichtiger punkt ändert sich jetzt
bislang mussten viele unternehmen der
virus krise bei überschuldung keine
insolvenz anmelden
damit ist ab dem ersten beschluss der
insolvenzantrag wird wie der pflicht die
große frage wie viele firmen sind
betroffen
antworten von jan hofer verweist und
fußgängerzonen geschlossenen restaurants
und lehre werkshallen die korona krise
trifft die wirtschaft hart mit der
rückkehr zur insolvenzantragspflicht
müssen viele unternehmen jetzt ihre
zahlungsunfähigkeit offenlegen mit 5000
insolvenzen rechnen experten viel
weniger jedoch als ursprünglich
befürchtet und bei dreieinhalb millionen
betrieben in deutschland für die
volkswirtschaft absolut verkraftbar so
der bankenverband wir banken brauchen
jetzt klarheit über den wirklichen
zustand der wirtschaft wir brauchen
transparenz insbesondere auch mit den
kleineren unternehmen geht deswegen
begrüßen wir diesen schritt ausdrücklich
wir müssen wissen wo wir stehen viele
unternehmen konnten nur überleben dank
des staatlichen hilfsprogramms insgesamt
350 milliarden euro hilfen und weitere
820 milliarden garantien in der größten
not war das richtig findet der
insolvenzverwalter christoph niering
diese phase sei jetzt aber vorbei gibt
es nicht zuviel trittbrettfahrer
unternehmen die kurzarbeitergeld
bekommen und gleichzeitig milliarden an
aktionäre ausschütten
zombie unternehmen wie sie genannt
werden die eigentlich kein
zukunftskonzept haben die man nur
künstlich am leben erhält da muss man
schon mal jetzt genauer hinschauen viele
kleinstbetriebe wie das restaurant um
die ecke schließen in der regel übrigens
ohne insolvenzantrag die korona krise
hinterlässt also durchaus sichtbare
spuren auch wenn eine große
insolvenzwelle
wohl ausbleibt für viele kinder und
jugendliche heißt pandemie auch viel
zeit vor dem computer nicht nur beim
homeschooling sondern auch in der
freizeit vor den gefahren die im netz
lauern sollen sie jetzt besser geschützt
werden
durch eine reform des
jugendschutzgesetzes die morgen in kraft
tritt unter anderem gibt es auflagen für
die großen player wie facebook und
youtube
aber auch für die gaming plattform über
das gesetz und die kritik daran jetzt
birgit franken im digitalen raum gibt es
keine grenzen mobbings sexualisierte
gewalt bilder von missbrauchten kindern
ich hatte die ehre auch noch nie gemacht
und ich wollte die auch eigentlich nicht
machen so was wie du das wollen wir hier
nicht haben so was wenn du sollte
verschwinden ein mann hat mir eine
nachricht geschickt wo er mich fragte ob
ich gegen bezahlung auf sein gesicht
treten würde
ein sexueller weise das neue
jugendschutzgesetz soll genau davor
besser schützen und nimmt social media
messenger dienste sowie gaming
plattformen in die pflicht es soll
einheitlicher alterskennzeichnungen für
filme und spiele im handel und online
geben waren funktionen vor kostenfallen
oder der möglichen ansprache durch
fremde vorsorgemaßnahmen wie
altersgerechte voreinstellungen und eine
neue bundeszentrale die das alles
überwacht und bußgelder verhängt und
genau hier bei der neuen zentrale
fürchten kritiker kompetenz-wirrwarr da
die medienaufsicht grundsätzlich bei den
ländern liegt noch ein größerer
kritikpunkt ist dass das neue gesetz
möglicherweise nicht für die
ausländischen player wie zb facebook
youtube und instagram gilt das
herkunftslandprinzip sagt ja dass
anbieter die ihren sitz in einem anderen
eu-mitgliedstaat nehmen also zb in
irland grundsätzlich nur irisches recht
beachten müssen also gerade nicht das
deutsche jugendschutzrecht ein erster
schritt ist mit der anpassung des
gesetzes ins digitale zeitalter getan
ob er die jugend wirklich schützen kann
muss sich zeigen
rheinland pfalz soll auch künftig von
einer ampelkoalition aus spd grünen und
fdp regiert werden
ministerpräsidentin dreier stellte heute
das regierungsprogramm für die nächsten
fünf jahre früher
so soll das land führenden
biotechnologie standort werden
weitere schwerpunkte sind klimaschutz
und eine zukunftsfähige infrastruktur
am donnerstag wollen die drei parteien
endgültig über den koalitionsvertrag
abstimmen
nochmal zurück zum thema corona ab heute
hat die türkei bis mindestens mitte mai
einen harten lockdown verordnet nur
wenige ausnahmen rechtfertigendes
unterwegs zu sein etwa berufe die die
regierung als essentiell einstuft
lebensmitteleinkäufe können nur noch zu
limitierten zeiten stattfinden alkohol
steht vorerst gar nicht mehr im regal
touristen sind nicht betroffen aber
deren zahl ist ohnehin überschaubar wie
die türken mit dem lockdown umgehen
zeigt glück wallbott
17 tage ausgangssperre rund um die uhr
nur apotheken und lebensmittelläden sind
für einige stunden geöffnet
doch trotz des lockdown zwar heute
geschäftiger betrieb auf istanbuls
straßen tausende bürger sind mit
sondergenehmigungen unterwegs auch weil
kern branchen wie bau wirtschaft und
industrie produktion von den
beschränkungen ausgenommen sind
trotzdem setzt die regierung auf die
wirksamkeit der schließungen
die bisherigen maßnahmen haben zwar die
infektionszahlen etwas gesenkt aber das
reicht nicht um das zu beschleunigen war
dieser lockdown unumgänglich
unumgänglich war nach auffassung der
regierung auch ein alkoholverbot während
des lockouts mit pandemie bekämpfung
habe das nichts zu tun so kritiker
sondern mit der islamischen agenda des
präsidenten im netz ging ein sturm der
entrüstung los in den lizensierten
alkohol eden herrschte gestern noch
hamster kaufstimmung ich weiß nicht was
sie damit erreichen wollen alle haben
einfach auf vorrat eingekauft unser haus
ist jetzt ein weinkeller touristen sind
von den ausgangs beschränkungen nicht
betroffen
allerdings sind wegen der hohen corona
zahlen kaum noch gäste im land nachdem
buchungs einbruch von 70 prozent im
letzten jahr hofft die branche auf
diesen sommer
unterdessen verließen gestern noch
tausende istanbuler die stadt um das
traditionelle zuckerfest zum ende des
ramadan in zwei wochen mit verwandten
oder im feriendomizil zu verbringen über
land reisen sind ab heute nur noch mit
sondergenehmigung erlaubt
und jetzt zu einem historischen schritt
der wiedergutmachung
deutsche museen werden im nächsten jahr
erste exemplare der sogenannten berlin
bronson zurückgeben
die 500 jahre alten tafeln und
skulpturen schmückten einst den palast
im königreich benin im heutigen nigeria
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts waren
die briten dort einmarschiert hatten die
kunstschätze geraubt und anschließend an
europäische museen verkauft stephan
merseburger es sind meisterwerke
afrikanische kunst die bienen großen
heiß begehrt und das ist der makel
raubkunst mehr als 1000 davon besitzen
die deutschen museen ab 2022 so
beschlossen politik und museen gestern
gemeinsam soll es wie es heißt zu
substanziellen rückgaben kommen
es geht darum dass wir unsere moralische
und historische verantwortung wahrnehmen
und nicht mehr nur darüber reden sondern
tatsächlich rückgaben in gang setzen
hierhin sollen sie zurückkehren benin
city im heutigen nigeria ein museum
westafrikanischer kunst wird hier
entstehen das braucht zeit geeignete
depots aber werden wohl bis 2022 fertig
früher war binnen ein königreich 1897
hatten britische kolonialtruppen bei
einer blutigen strafexpedition den
palast geplündert die erbeuteten großen
wurden weiter an europäische museen
verkauft die kriegs trophäen sind längst
zu einem symbol für koloniales unrecht
geworden
lange haben sich deutsche museen gegen
rückgabe forderungen gesträubt auch im
humboldt forum im berliner schloss
sollten sie bald gezeigt werden und
jetzt wir wollen weiterhin bronson
natürlich in berlin im humboldt-forum ab
sich ja auch an anderen deutschen museen
zeigen aber das wollen wir im
einverständnis mit der nigerianischen
seite tun unter welchen bedingungen es
möglich ist sicher ist will die großen
zeigt muss auch die blutige geschichte
dahinter erzählen
zum sport und zum atp tennisturnier in
münchen arbeitet ja und da gab es heute
eine faustdicke überraschung
deutschlands bester tennisspieler und
top favorit alexander zverev ist raus er
verliert seinen viertelfinal spiel gegen
einen qualifikanten aus belarus früh ist
es ihm anzusehen es läuft nicht wie
gewünscht und diva spa ist ein ernst zu
nehmender gegner obwohl nur 100 siebter
der weltrangliste
es wäre schaffte es nach einem
verlorenen aufschlagspiel den ersten
satz noch im tie-break knapp für sich zu
entscheiden
mühevoll mit 7 zu 5 im zweiten satz ist
der zwei punkte vom matchgewinn entfernt
verliert aber dann drei spiele in folge
und diva spielt immer besser
75 für den mann aus biel aus im
entscheidenden dritten durchgang geräts
wäre schnell mit 1 4 in rückstand allzu
selten gelingen ihn gut vorbereitete
angriffe kurz die hoffnung nach diesem
rebreak
er verliert gleich wieder sein nächstes
aufschlagspiel eines von iwata zum 6 2 3
und 1 sichtlich um seine bestform
bringen alexanders wäre er muss die
hoffnung auf den dritten turnier gewinne
in münchen begraben auf die deutsche
nummer zwei dagegen ist verlass jan
lennard struff hat das halbfinale in
münchen erreicht
ja dieses wochenende keine
fußball-bundesliga dafür die beiden dfb
pokal halbfinals morgen spielt der bvb
gegen den zweitligisten und pokalschreck
holstein kiel und heute abend trifft
werder bremen auf rb leipzig wenn das
flutlicht an geht heute abend im
weserstadion könnten die vorzeichen kaum
unterschiedlicher sein für beide trainer
der eine möchte einen titel zum absprung
in die nächsthöhere trainer liga der
andere seinen job behalten
niemand muss das gefühl haben dass jetzt
der druck auf seinen schultern liegt am
freitag habe ich danach noch trainer bin
oder nicht die sachsen und ihr noch
trainer wollen nach der gewonnenen
generalprobe in der liga jetzt ihren
ersten titel überhaupt anpeilen
ja natürlich wäre es sehr schön wenn wir
uns mit dem pokal verabschieden würden
klappt es ja klar würden gerne alle den
titel gewinnen für kurve zukunft dürfte
entscheidend sein wie sich seine
mannschaft heute verkauft auf das
verhältnis von licht und schatten licht
und schatten das was im sport danke
norbert und wir schauen noch nach
portugal wo es ab heute einen besonderen
nervenkitzel gibt über einer schlucht
spannt sich die längste fußgänger
hängebrücke der welt 516 meter lang 175
meter hoch sicher aufgehängt aber mit
einem metallgitter als boden der blick
nach unten ist somit nichts bei
höhenangst
ablenken kann aber vielleicht der
herrliche ausblick ist ja nur für starke
nerven
der tanz in den mai ist gestrichen aber
auch mit spazierengehen wird es wohl
nichts das wochenende bietet ergiebigen
regen wie uns gleich es sind erklärt so
viel von uns für heute danke für ihr
interesse
christian sievers freut sich um 10 auf
sie im heute journal und uns gibt es
morgen wieder um sie einen schönen
wochenausklang für sie es
[Musik]
ein guter abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter gleich mit drei tiefs haben
wir uns in den nächsten tagen zu tun
dieses kleid hier verabschiedet sich
relativ rasch und auch das im norden
aber schauen sie dass hier das kommt
morgen am nachmittag auf und bis sonntag
kaum ergiebige regenmengen im süden
deutschlands zusammen in der nacht gibt
es also bereits regen das wird
allmählich weniger im westen lockert es
auf und die temperaturen sinken dort bis
auf minus zwei grad und 8 grad im
südosten deutschlands morgen
tagesverlauf noch regen im osten
deutschlands und auch nach norden im
westen gibt sonnenschein aber der regen
hier im südwesten der wird immer mehr
und wird allmählich im tagesverlauf
richtung nordosten ziehen und in der
nacht und am sonntag für viel regen
sorgen und das bei höchsten temperaturen
bis 19 grad im südosten deutschlands
sonst bei 11 bis 16
an der ostsee um 10 grad der kräftige
regen also am sonntag der erreicht vor
allem den süden und zieht nach nordosten
8 bis 14 grad die höchsten temperaturen
montag bis 16 grad warm und schauen sie
auf den dienstag da erreicht uns ein
sturmtief im nordwesten mit viel regen
damit ein schöner abend